un regard un regard magnifique on a eu
une semaine de stage avant la régate des
conditions de vent et le soleil
exceptionnel et puis une jolie régate
avec le 12 manches un comité bien à
l'écouté des coureurs et des entraîneurs
vraiment une super semaine c'était
vraiment magique bilan super positif
parce qu'on avait l'intention de
s'entraîner dans le vent on a été gâté
il ya eu durant toute la semaine
donc voilà on a bien progressé on a
travaillé dur un peu près 50 heures de
navigation sur la semaine donc voilà
c'est une super semaine à les
martiniquais ils vont bien l'écart
allait bien vont bien dans le vent ce
sont des gabarits un peu puissant donc
on voulait s'étalonner un petit peu
vis-à-vis d'eux et on a bien travaillé
on a en a tenu la distance on est devant
donc voilà c'est un bilan super positif